I just saw my favorite video that I've
seen on the Internet in many many weeks
this comes out of Camden New Jersey so
the Democratic governor of New Jersey
Phil Murphy is pushing pretty heavy
draconian lockdown measures not just
reasonable measures to allow two people
to protect their own public health but
but they're really ownerís measures here
and the people of Camden just don't want
to hear it anymore so they decide
they're gonna start reopening the cops
get called to the reopening and we're
not by the way they're not reopening
businesses like a hundred percent right
away there was a gym in Camden that
opened at just 20 percent capacity and
they had a bunch of other extra
coronavirus precautions in place they
had fever checks at this gym you want to
go work out you got to get your
temperature taken before you you walk in
so these people are being very cautious
very responsible still the cops get
called to the gym to shut it down but
one cop wasn't having it you know there
was a big crowd of people around at the
gym and the cop walked up he said
technically you're all in violation of
the law but have a nice day normally you
are all in violation of the executive
orders what do you Hank no one that
knows have a good day everybody
I love this guy we need to get this cop
a Medal of Freedom this is such the
right attitude a lot of our system of
government is premise taun the idea that
various branches various departments
various levels will push back on the
others and we will avoid tyranny because
everybody's got these sort of more local
interests a different understanding of
different communities and so you can you
can push back on things and that's
exactly what this cop did absolutely
terrific stuff you see in California
these ridiculous cops chasing a
paddleboarder around in the middle of
the ocean paddleboarders not near
anybody and the cops are trying to chase
him down on boards and boats and things
like that obviously absurd in New Jersey
the cop walks up because look
everybody's being very safe you've got
masks on your 20% you're taking people's
temperatures you couldn't possibly be
more responsible technically you're in
violation of this dumb law but have a
nice day the Governor of New Jersey
didn't like that much Murphy said quote
I'm not concerned it will spiral out of
control and we will take action if you
show up at that gym again tomorrow
there's going to be a different reality
than showing up today these aren't just
words
we've got to enforce this but I also
don't want to start World War three okay
all right pal I think your threats are a
little bit empty
because what what this cop showed what
those people who were protesting the
lockdown showed is that especially in a
democratic republic the politicians
can't lead people where they don't want
to go and there's a whole lot of bluster
and there's a whole lot of power
grabbing going on but ultimately these
politicians are still in many ways
accountable so the people look at the
phrasing that the governor uses it's
going to be different tomorrow these
aren't just words it's not that he's
worried about protecting public health
it's that he's worried about losing
credibility and I think that's true for
a lot of the overreaching politicians
here all of their predictions have not
come true we haven't come close to
overwhelming the health care system
we've we've social
distance we've done all these policies
virtually perfectly and the prediction
models haven't come true and there's no
end to them in sight
all right the We the People have upheld
our end of the bargain remember 15 days
to slow the spread we did it we did it
we stayed at home we abided by these
policies right and yet
day by day it seems clearer and clearer
that the policies have had very little
if any effect at all and day by day it's
clearer and clearer that the timetable
that we were told we had to use these
policies is being extended constantly we
held up our end of the bargain the
politicians and the labcoat dictators
did not hold up their end of the bargain
we the people who predicted that hmm
maybe this isn't going to turn out the
way the doomsdayers are saying it will
we the people who were a little bit
skeptical about this whole thing turned
out to be right and the lab coat
hysterics and the politicians who
insisted out those outsourced our entire
politics to them turned out to be wrong
and now we've had enough so we're gonna
push back and you know what those guys
are gonna do in their state capitals and
in their lab coats they're gonna do
absolutely nothing about it because
ultimately they don't have nearly as
much power as they want to pretend that
they do
[Music]
[Music]